The youth unemployment rate is incredibly high across
Ontario.
Right now, I can't find work for anything, even though I've got 13 years
experience doing this kind of stuff. It like, it sucks.
It's my word against anyone else's word, right?
Being in workforce development, we've been hearing for a long time that there's a
big shortage when it comes to the trades.
We sought out some relationship development with
construction organizations, different employers, as well as training centers.
Currently, there is over 220 employers within Barrie
that are looking to fill in positions within the manufacturing or construction
field.
What made me decide to join this course was it seemed like a better opportunity for
me to, progress in the, construction industry and to
get my hands kind of wet.
Each and every single trade kind of varies, so here we kind of learn like the
general aspect of, you know, how to work safely within, you know, the
construction site.
I joined the program essentially to get better
opportunity. Everyone was very inclusive, and they treated everyone the
same, so it was... It's been great.
I speak to employers every day. Soft skills are the most
critical. Dependability, reliability.
The demand in Barrie is very high. They're expecting to grow the
construction and manufacturing field within the next five years.
It helps employers not having to put you through these
certificates again. It's easier to get a job when you're already certified for
multiple things.
This particular cohort is directly related to the
skills and certifications that they need to get employment in the
trades.
To be able to contribute more to the community, I would think, would be just
positively
making things cleaner and better.
To see my actual work in progress and then to see how it
affects others in their daily lives.
Or just contributing to, you know, the evolution of society.
I think it's good just being able to provide value in that aspect.
It's not just giving them the entry level certifications that they need to get into
a role in construction. It's also giving them an opportunity to
show that they are ready for a
job.